the mood across Nisha is somber as a
country mourns the string of losses
recently suffered by the Army has shaken
many here and raised concerns about the
future tsuki minutes at the gate
illogical the attackers are trying to
conquer territory I think once they are
done with this country they will move on
to another they have a global agenda
after the devastating loss at Shin ago
dare the government of nazar is
struggling to deal with the fallout from
the attack what you need to know is the
whole of the Sahel is unstable leaders
in the region are collaborating our
soldiers are doing their best and need
the support of everyone it's not easy
but we hope things will improve
we hope the hardship we're going through
will pass soon president Mahamadou
issoufou joined leaders of Mauritania
Mali Chad and Burkina Faso for a summit
with French president Emmanuel macron II
Paul France but not before making
changes in Asia's military leadership a
move described as too little too late
for victims of the attacks
Sufism on a yearly before and here
unfortunately burns the brunt of the
attacks the new appointments are coming
after much damage is done the problem is
structural families who lost members are
mourning and will continue to do so what
government needs to do is to take
measures to prevent this from happening
major like most countries of the Sahel
is facing an uncertain future in less
than two months 160 of its soldiers have
been killed by armed groups this
monument was built in the centre of the
city in honor of the 71 soldiers killed
in an attack last month another 89
soldiers were killed in another attack
last week the threat from armed groups
is a major concern for people especially
those living in areas close to the
border with Mali and Nigeria three days
of national mourning is underway people
in the Sahel countries who are now
becoming more accustomed to these
attacks wonder why the armed groups
will strike next Hamid II trees al
Jazeera yeah me
Misha